the owners of a Winston Churchill themed
cafe in London probably didn't think
they were doing anything out of the
ordinary but in times such as these even
considering Churchill or war hero is
apparently controversial to my
embarrassment 14 members of my old
university Sohus held a protest
demanding the owner apologize for a
grand izing the wartime leader rather
than portraying him as a racist the
demonstrators faced a backlash but their
student union backed them saying that
the cafe quote exercises a concerted
historical amnesia of British
colonialism offensive to those who
continue to experience institutional
racism not to me and thousands like me
it doesn't
of course Churchill was flawed just as
Gandhi and all great historical leaders
were but they're more troublesome ideas
were relatively banal during the times
that they lived in and their
achievements outshine their shortcomings
these two criteria must surely apply
otherwise no historical figure is safe
from being torn down the arrogance of
presence ISM judging historical figures
by today's morality that is is dangerous
and ignores the true complexity of human
nature
I mean Churchill defeated Hitler for
goodness sake if we can't celebrate him
who can we celebrate
[Music]
Majid I'm gonna start by asking you a
question please do do you think we in
Britain today have a healthy and honest
relationship with our history no no I
don't and I'll give you one example I
studied history at a-level and I studied
what I was taught was the Indian Mutiny
now I don't think that was a mutiny my
by the way my origins are South Asian my
father immigrated from Pakistan I think
it was a rebellion against colonialism
but it's still called a mutineer somehow
indicating it's wrong but you know
that's not the point what we're not
talking about here of what is a robust
and healthy debate about the merits and
the demerits of historical figures like
Churchill what I'm raising is the fact
that these students stormed a cafe and
refused to leave and and and well some
how oblivious to the fact that every
great historical leader not just
Churchill but Gandhi Mandela they will
all if we subject to them so this sort
of lens where we started protesting that
that you know we don't open cafes in
their names we'll have nothing and
nobody left to celebrate the history I
think you and these students actually
have more in common than you realize oh
yeah we both went to so I was a student
in an officer there I think you actually
have a lot more in common than I realize
because the reason and I'm not part of
their movement but the reason that I
think they're doing this and the reason
I can relate to them doing it is their
frustration that what you said we should
have which is a healthy and robust
relationship with history is not being
had you talked about the complexity of
historical figures most British people
do not know Churchill as a complex human
being they know him as a one-dimensional
simplistic historical figure ie a
wartime here at which he was I am NOT
going to sit here and say that I'm not
glad that Churchill was able to defeat
Nazism you know my own family suffered
directly from Nazism as German Jews so
it's not that I am certain that people
don't know the history during the
generation that's not an insult to them
it's because we don't tell them the
truth it's not recorded it's people he's
not in the his bigotries and his his
bigotries were recorded there were a
matter and do you think they are part of
the popular understanding of Hitler
you have to understand there are people
for our time and yes some of his views
were horrendous but but his pettiness
and his bigotries were nowhere near as
horrendous as the horrors that were
unleashed by Hitler and he was a man of
our time and people are forgetting it's
easy to forget how close we came to
surrendering to Hitler a lot of
politicians in this country wanted to do
it a lot of the aristocrats in this
country want to do it and he saw the
evil let me finish he saw the evils of
Nazism long before the rest of Europe
did okay let's say that you know I don't
think to be honest taking on board your
point that there isn't an awareness of
the of the merits and the demerits of
any great historical figure but
something tells me these students
wouldn't storm the Gandhi statue yeah in
in in Bloomsbury and try and protest
that being there despite the fact that
Gandhi was also had racist views as you
know after why I think it's interesting
you raised that because I even you're
making assumptions there are many
African of a high example in Ghana in
Ghana which is my mother's country
they've removed the statue and EQ
because there is growing awareness about
heroes and that wants to celebrate a man
who took this country by the mantle and
led us to victory in a war that was over
lose
it's easy for you to say that if you
were of Bengali descent for example and
there are many people who have been
personally hurt by the likes of that
well you said Venus Carroll use the word
pettiness million people who died in an
avoidable prevent for a woman which
Churchill could have prevented okay and
instead he devoted a away from it and
exported food for India due to breeches
true that is not I do want to say though
that is a 2.1 million people died and
there is a historical debate as to
exactly what role Churchill played in it
but it's a debate and actually as none
of those students were of South Asian
origin in fact no one around this table
apart from
and I'm not offended at the Churchill
caffeine no student told Harold on Pell
those students were offended on my
behalf and I find that South Asian
claiming people like me that's the exact
quote of the protesters the exact quote
with the protesters I'm going to read it
right the basis Students Union said this
cafe exercises a concerted historical
amnesia of British colonialism which is
offensive to those who continue to
experience institutional right my point
they were claiming offense on my behind
as I continue to experience not just
every one but specifically you mentioned
the famine so I'm gonna say specifically
South Asia and that's me right and I'm
saying none of those students were from
South Asia in fact the the leader of
what was originally Somali and I think
actually to claim offense to speak as if
we all think the same way about this is
actually quite offensive I just work
before MIT comes available I think we
need to own one of these issues that
somebody who's interested in Britishness
as an identity Nick before you do sorry
the cafe owner has something to say
about this I think we should hear from
people just read I'm gonna read what he
said and then Nick of course you get you
can come in and say something too but
Chris Evans is the Kevin not not that
Chris Evans but it's Evans he says if
you cannot celebrate Britain and Great
Britain's you're just amazing history
and if you cannot celebrate Churchill
you cannot celebrate anyone I'd say to
the protesters come in have a cup of tea
let's have a debate about it because if
what you're saying is that we cannot
celebrate these leaders does that mean
that we cannot celebrate any human being
ever Nick
I think the clue is in the name it's
called the Blighty cafe you probably
know what you're going to get when you
go there after you're a very very smart
woman I worry that you think that your
interpretation of history is in some
ways superior to other peoples or that
is the one that we should all sign up to
and ultimately there will be no one
there were mother to raiser I'm sure we
can probably find that you never
returned a library book if we work long
and hard enough there will be some
reason Perry not planning a library
break to house it
just the most another recent one which I
want to bring in and put and put before
the court is Gladstone William Gladstone
his students up in Liverpool University
now want his name removed from one of
the buildings up there they say his
career was funded by his father Sir John
Gladstone that in turn was built on the
back of the slave trade so the student
body says it should be named after one
of the people who attended there so this
suggests if we called the John Snow
Hall as in the newsreader that is the
path down which we are treading we are
it's a bit like Zulu which is a glorious
testament to British heroism we are
supporting and praising and celebrating
a tremendous British hero that's the
question so figuratively of course yes
not to be endorsing colonial what we do
at the table here's my question and that
is it
you know if we're not comfortable with
Churchill I presume Gandhi would come
under the same kind of criticism who
should we celebrate from history who is
by the way fits that criteria that
you've put forward that you know that
hasn't got any of that kind of thing I
think the problem is in the question
right as soon as you take a celebratory
approach to history you're already
running into trouble because like we're
all saying when you when you decide as a
successively desired you know David
Cameron
Gordon Brown Michael Gove that we should
celebrate the great history of these
islands you're telling me you don't want
to acknowledge that we basically help
design and perpetrate the slave trade
for 400 years that we colonize the world
on a white supremacist ideology that we
have people that we hold in high I think
that we should look at people in very
quick is there any figure you wanna
celebrate just very quick I personally
I'm not comfortable with the celebrated
approaches you so terrible trying
climbing creamer who I really look up to
Ghana's independence leader a flawed man
you know he ended up basically running
is occasionally but I still think
there's lots to celebrate mystery I bet
many British people haven't heard of him
despite the fact he played a fundamental
role in shaping Britain's 20th century
history so you done so there is a lot
that most of us don't knows well because
I have a superior understanding history
Nick it's just that I'm interested and a
lot of people don't think I just feel
the people in the cafe who went for a
bit of breakfast sandwiches